[Musik]
schon seit vielen jahren hat lobt die
lautlos das elend vor augen durch daran
gewöhnen konnte sie sich nie
da geht es mir so schlecht was ich noch
sagen
ihr herz schlägt für die ärmsten in der
elfenbeinküste
tausende menschen konnte sie schon vor
dem tod retten
seit 23 jahren lebt die schweizerin im
slum von abidjan viele sich seither
geschehen was sich alles in ihrem leben
verändert hat davon handelt dieser
reportage
[Musik]
es war
2099 die schweizerin zum ersten mal in
afrika besuchte in ihrem damaligen
central sp nahm sie waisenkinder auf
deren eltern an aids gestorben waren
auch ein ambulatorium gehörte zum
hilfswerk nur kranke behandelt wurden
für schwerstkranke führte die schweiz in
ein sterbehospiz
[Musik]
doch dann wurde sie 2016 fast dazu
gezwungen ihr lebenswerk aufzugeben das
sontra lesbar ist heute eine ruine
da haben wir super
startzeit hat dass der flugplatz selbst
vergrößert werde und dass baustraße
juroren und ich weiß nicht genau was man
wähle machen ob einer ein offizielles
dokument über moment gebeten worden sind
scorsese natrue system an es fällt ihm
schwer an jenen ort zurückzukehren wo
einst vielen leuten geholfen wurde
ich bin traurig jetzt ist alles zerstört
ich dachte andere leute könnten es
nutzen aber dass carmen drogenhändler
verkauften in der nacht drogen haschisch
tabletten und lsd
dann kamen die bulldozer der regierung
obwohl sie den islamischen vor sechs
jahren verlassen hat bleibt sie als
schutzpatronin präsent
[Applaus]
[Musik]
richtigen stoff
[Gelächter]
warendorf
zum glück geht diese geschichte weiter
nach langem suchen fand das ehepaar otto
seine neue heimat sie liegt in einem
vorort von abidjan und heißt sandra
izbasa
[Musik]
denn hopfenland suchen auch wieder
wählen ihn ins lamm zurück und dann habe
ich langsam echt und land gesucht und
haben den afrikanischen freunde der hat
durchs kurve und dann hätte als
landstück gefunden oder mehr zeit hat
und dadurch sei aber rasch aus dass ich
als unfähig
aber ich hoffe dass hinter dem gebiet in
slim hat da wollte sie unbedingt hin
aber das sumpfige land musste zuerst
trockengelegt werden
das war dann die aufgabe von ehemann
assis einem passionierten bau erschien
her
es gab viel wasser hier niemand wollte
etwas machen zu haben pfeiler in den
boden gerammt um ein fundament zu
konstruieren darauf bauen wir das neue
senden das war teurer als eine normale
konstruktion aber wenigstens konnten wir
das grundstück nutzbar machen und wenn
man sich umschaut wir sind umgeben von
einem slum lotti ist ja glücklich dieses
grundstück gefunden zu haben
[Musik]
nein
in seinem berufsleben leitete assist
projekte heute ist er der technikchef
des hilfswerks
[Musik]
ich mache das mit leidenschaft das ist
klar aber gleichzeitig bringe ich den
leuten das handwerk bei
ich werde erst ich bin 74 jährige
vermutlich werde ich bald selber nach
hierher kommen deshalb muss ich mein
wissen weitergeben
sie ist doch wie gut er das macht im
klein und so hält es besser
das neue sorte wurde im januar 2017
eröffnet es gibt über 50 personen eine
neue heimat darunter 35 waisenkindern
[Musik]
regelmäßig kommen jugendliche zu besuch
für die lobt die eine ersatzmutter ist
es sind waisenkinder dem sontra
aufgewachsen sind
was ist wenn auch hin wo sie sind wo das
letzte mal vor zwölf jahren das ist
derart groß
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
zwölf jahre zuvor all diese waisenkinder
von der zuflucht
[Musik]
das sind daher weiß ich bin also die
mittleren meint denn die baby da und
dann sind das die mittlere ganz klinik
wo es kommt auch sehen dass etwas
schaust oder aus unserem herzkind und
der märkte tut einfach logisch sind
dumme du dein onkel
meinte sogar man will sehen sie ist ganz
herzlich empfangen gebinde der tour sind
um wirklich
dass ich ganz ganz schwer unterernährt
sind und er wird sicher chronische
neurologische
zwei jahren
entwickelt oder
das ist
[Musik]
der spezielle sparen
und dadurch sehr intelligenter schaut
dass alles was man seit der jugend
schaffen
alle die bei loki lautlos aufgewachsen
sind machen heute ihren weg dank ihrer
finanziellen unterstützung
der anschmachten batterie leer boris
kodjoe
gelang machte hochlädt und
data ist politische student der politik
studieren aber er wollte nachher über
psychologie
ich kam sterbend hier an
ich war neun jahre alt und war nahe am
tod
mir wurde liebe gegeben
herzlichkeit anerkennung
teilen habe hier gelernt all das
auch pflege und ausbildung habe ich
erhalten einfach alles
das hilfswerk von lotus ist heute größer
denn je auf dem über 7000 quadratmeter
großen gelände gibt es im alten ort auch
ein ambulatorium bis zu 250
hilfesuchende kommen tägliche her
[Musik]
medikamente und medizinische beratungen
sind gratis
[Musik]
moderne operatoren und ausgebildetes
pflegepersonal unter leitung von drei
ärzten betreuen die kranken die geräte
sind eine spende der schweizer
eidgenossenschaft
die fünfjährige maria liegt an einer
entzündung des gehirns daraus
entwickelte sich ein wasserkopf
[Musik]
nun soll dem mädchen blut entnommen
werden durch ist glaubt nicht sie hat zu
wenig davon
[Musik]
viermal wurde marian bereits operiert
ihr zustand besserte sich nicht so viel
autos muss der mutter nur mitteilen dass
es für ihr kind keine hoffnung mehr gibt
glaubst du an gott mama
bist du
du hast noch zwei andere kinder
wenn gott uns ein kind schenkt leite es
uns nur
er schenkt es uns nicht
manchmal sind die pläne des herrn anders
gott wird sie bald zu sich rufen damit
sie aufhört zu leiden
an seiner seite wird sie frieden finden
dann gibt es kein leiden mir
ich weiß dass ihr muslimin ist sehr
stunden in völliger lautstark und will
wenn sie mir seid ja
also ich will gut sind einfach gläubig
danach an ich wünsche dass gott zu hilfe
und mv ist für mich einfacher
motorvision
bagis abc news sie weiß schon dass jedes
kind später für einmal steht
wer sich immer wieder schwere
nur wenige tage nach diesem gespräch hat
maria um diese welt verlassen
daneben das soep ist wirklich schwierig
rund grund nach irgendwo wohnen ist
glücklich macht wo ist seither aber
wieder machen
[Musik]
rundum lotti latrous oase breitet sich
das elend aus sie nimmt damit für einen
rundgang durch den islam der heute 22
jährige kam als waisenkind hilfswerk und
wuchs dort auf wir sind mit dem quartier
das wüssten wie es in der realität sind
foto verdeckt muss eigentlich herkommt
sich haben könnte erinnere wie ist krieg
sie sind hotel treibstoffe sind um sie
zu hause sind und sind einfach müssen
wir was wir alles an was wir das projekt
geäußert
trotz oder vor allem
die äußerst jedoch mit wenn man alle
wirklich sehen wo überhaupt werk hoffen
kann und überhaupt kasten hand dass sie
mir das wissen versperrt
fast die hälfte der einwohner in der
elfenbeinküste lebt unter der
armutsgrenze
hunderttausende haben nicht genug zu
essen und keine arbeit
sommerfeld
das berührt mich sehr
leute zu sehen die so leben müssen das
treibt mich an hart zu arbeiten um
vorwärts zu kommen
darum möchte ich im humanitären bereich
tätig sein und leuten zu helfen die so
in armut leben wie ich es auch hätte tun
müssen
[Musik]
viele haben keinen strom es mangelt an
sauberem trinkwasser und sanitären
einrichtungen
im innenhof
bahnhof ist innerhofer umringt wird vom
ufer
willkommen königshofer und die strecke
gemeinsam 3 liter und
durch ruhm
als mindestens zwei familien und die
familie hat vielleicht auch
familienangehörige sagen wir mal
550 personen platz und was mit duschen
und toiletten ich sage ich mit großer so
ist der schlacht die monarchie und da
hat sie malen hannemann vorderachse aber
es ist mit silikon
malaria und tuberkulose sind hier weit
verbreitet in öffentlichen
krankenhäusern erhält nur hilfe mehr
bezahlen kann
wenig später wird die laut ross entdeckt
eine frau mit einer offenen wunde
du solltest auf jeden fall einen verband
maschinelle problems apple die wunde
kann sich komplett infizieren und dann
gibt es eine blutvergiftung
du kannst darin sternen du kannst zu uns
kommen wir reinigen die wunde und
verbinden sie
bist du einverstanden
es kostet dich nicht
durch die frau taucht nie im
ambulatorium auf sie vertraue der
modernen medizin nicht ließ sie
ausrichten
am meisten fürchten sich die menschen in
den slums vor einer krankheit die alle
nur la mala die nennen gemeint ist aids
im jahre 2009 starben im sontra lesbar
jede woche bis zu fünf menschen an aids
und deshalb darf meine frau vielleicht
darüber und über die anderen sind am
start
wie geht es dir
sie will sich hin leben ich helfe dir
wir drehen sie ein bisschen
das ist vorbei
die frau ist schon in sie wurde gerade
einmal 28 jahre alt
die lautlos stand schon unzählige
menschen werden ihren letzten stunden
bei
am anfang hat hat mir dass sie hauptbau
kabarett mit gott oder www verstanden
wieso das er entnimmt und alle die
menschen in tradierten intro hand und da
nicht merkt dass das nützt dass das
nicht immer man positiv ist dass ich
total ist alles negative
negativs typs und der zeitlos es ist
einfach so und das habe ich in afrika
vor allem klingt auch alles was gut
gemacht ich gut auch im neuen zentrum
befindet sich eine klinik durch lotti
latrous nennt diese nicht mehr wie
früher sterben spital dank besserer
medikamente überleben heute viel mehr
menschen krankheiten wie aids epidemie
du kannst dein hier drauf legen die ganz
vorsichtig
medizin
medizinisch tour das ist ganz einfach
wenn wir sie zu berühren
also ich seine streiche
und
jahren
mit das unter richard tauber ist geht es
nach ich dir nicht wie laut sicher dass
hörer
es gab mir einfach darum
eine mannschaft würde zu behaupten
manche tour de ski seine mannschaft sage
du bist genau so wichtig wie nie
alles hat ein ende sowohl das gute als
auch das schlechte
eines tages wird es dir besser gehen
nach dir keine sorgen
da schon etwas mir das kurz gefühl gibt
dass ist es glüht 15 draus ich muss das
machen
damit ein wortführer der welt das muss
gemacht werden und wenn ich das mache
dann muss es machen
in der schweiz blieb ihr einsatz im slum
von abidjan nicht unbemerkt
2004 durfte local autos eine hohe
auszeichnung entgegennehmen
[Applaus]
welcher moment für eine frau die nie
einen beruf erlernt hat
von da an ist ja eine ikone der schweiz
der angelpunkt der familie lotus war
damals ein haus unweit von genf wenn not
in der schweiz war kamen jeweils auf die
zu besuch hier trug sie zum ersten mal
ihren enkel sinai in den namen
die familie lebte bis um die
jahrtausendwende in der elfenbeinküste
kurz nach dem lot die ihr hilfswerk
gegründet hatte wurde er man es von
seiner firma nach ägypten versetzt dort
brauchte man die tunesier als leiter für
ein ingenieur projekt er und die drei
kinder gingen nach kairo blieb in
abidjan eine entscheidung unter der sie
liegt
[Musik]
das ihrer familie verlangen dass
wenn wir alle den gleichen ort können
aber
mittellosen
schwierig so
dass ich ihn vor innerhalb dieser
verlange dass mir
diese schmerzen
haben wir sagen nicht gut jetzt nimmer
unbedingt mitteilen
dass er ja der egoist 7 und einfach so
viel verlangt und der worte davon eine
uni sei gebürgt
unter der trennung liegt vor allem sarah
die neun jahre alt war als die mutter
ging
sie hat sich so entschieden ich denke
darüber nicht nach
durch die wunden waren damals noch nicht
verheilt sarah verließ weinend den raum
wenigsten sich nur mit new york sind und
dass das sichere jedem tiefen inneren
herzen und wenn es wieder das sach- und
sollte wie es manchmal lieber nur so und
das dann einfach immer noch weh tut dass
sie das montags ist vielleicht wo sie
gebraucht hätte
heute ist auch sarah teil dieser
großfamilie
jetzt hat das doch alles akzeptiert und
verstanden
und sie liebte sind genauso wie wenn sie
ihre brüder und schwestern sie sage du
zurzeit übrigens mindestlöhne brüder und
schwestern und sie schauen wichtige
weichen
stiftung oder und
was bedeutet
das eigentlich
jetzt also mitgemacht
es ist das letzte was
hat sich einfach
alles gepackt
wo die saemann aussichtslos ist im
hilfswerk nicht nur für das technische
zuständig noch weit mehr fähigkeiten
der koch hier
ja ich bin der boss in der kirche im
leben ist es nicht wichtig wer der chef
ist es ist wichtiger eine ausgeglichene
beziehung zu führen also immer zu
schauen wer der boss ist
ist es manchmal schwierig mit leuten
zusammen zu sein sich durch sehr
willensstark
ja klar ist kann er ja kommt sie gerade
[Musik]
manchmal ist es schwierig aber nicht
wenn sie sich das in den kopf gesetzt
habe könne sie sehr stur sein sagt das
ist
und wenn einmal etwas nicht nach plan
laufe verliere sie schnell einmal die
nerven
so jetzt rufe nach bitz mit
weil das hilfswerk der schweizerin in
den letzten jahren immer größer wurde
benötigt es auch mehr geld
100000 franken sind es monatlich die
dank spendengeldern aus der schweiz
zusammen kommen
noch die autos beschäftigt heute über 80
mitarbeitende
[Musik]
stolz ist die schweizerin aus regensberg
auch auf ihr neuestes projekt
jetzt fand vor während ingo wiegmann
hans fertig macht keinen profit aus der
schweiz und ich bin da viren und haben
jetzt immer schwer verbreitet hin und
her einfach alles gab und das dürfte ist
für
auto oder auch die und behinderte
personen
in den dreizehn häuschen leben etwas
mehr als 20 menschen
auch diese dreiköpfige familie hat hier
ein neues zuhause gefunden
samuel ist gelähmt
was hat er dann das an den berufsschulen
kostümen aber
ich bin von einer kokospalme
was hast du denn auf dieser kokospalme
gesucht da kommt
also was hast du denn auf diesem blöden
pokus nußbaum
hatte
du hattest hunger du wolltest eine
kokosnuss holen zum essen
da wurden hat coco porsche
ein
neues duett
ich weiß es nicht
nichts im leben geschieht ohne grund
dank dieses unglücks habe ich leute
kennengelernt
es nützt nichts wenn man es bereut man
akzeptiert sein schicksal
genau das
bringt nichts
dann
klappt das engagement kann der 29 jahre
alte samuel und die matura nachholen mit
spezial fach deutsch
[Musik]
was sie an
der schule
seit der gründung des hilfswerks vor 23
jahren haben hunderttausende menschen
wieder eine perspektive gefunden
so auch bergarbeiter frank der bei einem
minenunglück schwer verletzt wurde er
hat also als bei
verlorenes bei aber was maschine risch
hat sind die wirkung schüler hat sich
geschädigt wurden also erich hütter
klemmt und eis bayerische amputiert weil
er dort dürfe oder es gibt das
verlässliche mit dem nein es geht eine
andere lösung für ihn will er wird
unbedingt einen beruf lernen
dann haben jetzt
etwas herum westen wird machen aber eine
sehr gute schulausbildung und jetzt hat
er würde gern lernen die tore
schmutzler und es also endlich gefunden
wo schmuck gemacht und der und jetzt
zweimal in der woche von der
unterricht über
68 jahre alt bis sie inzwischen geworden
noch ist die voller tatendrang und mit
herzblut dabei aber auch ihre energien
sind nicht unerschöpflich
ich werde alt ich kann vielleicht nicht
mehr aufstehen
wird es immer
der tafel befindet wo das wirklich gut
übernervösen geist wieder macht wie das
ist natürlich voraussetzung dass er
begeistert da blieb das
kühlhaus gefühl heraus ist model das
gefühl hat man es ist der
personalbestand
damit wir die personen führen und das
gar nicht so klar dass gott sich das ja
ich habe mir vorstellen dass viele gar
nicht dass ich ja sehr wahr und energie
mitunter aber kurz vertraut mit den
frauen
wo andere sich sorgen machen würden grad
lockt die laut ross brawn eine fügung
des schicksals
dass sie ihre kraft im orden menschen
beizustehen
[Musik]